j'aimerais beaucoup vous présenter
quelqu'un
une ville d'angoulême
lucien de rubempré
pour vous servir
[Musique]
pour lui la poésie est une chose sacrée
sorte de religion intime qu'il fouille
de partir ensemble baril
j'ai besoin de travailler monsieur je
respecte énormément le métier de
journaliste et tu crois que c'est quoi
mon métier
vous éclairer les gens sur bar
le monde
mon métier c'est d'enrichir les
actionnaires du journal
d'autres lignes éditoriales se
rassemblent le journal tiendra pour vrai
tout ce qui est probable
je sais qu'il vaut mieux que cela on
croyait
tous ces magouilles du bruit du vent il
nous faut apprendre à jouer avec tout ça
[Musique]
tout est pourri partout tu trouves pas
vous battre pour faire des belles choses
[Musique]
de la mauvaise poire
la fausse rumeur et de l' annonce
publicitaire
je te baptise journalistes
[Musique]
nous à travailler dessus bien
il faut la barre
il faut taper là où ça fait mal
trop tard pour avoir peur
[Musique]
ce soir vous avez été incroyablement ce
point est fait kiffer aman
aman metelo
éviter de lancer notre label entendait
et va s'appeler apache musique
maintenant faut comprendre faire est ce
que vous êtes déjà à chaussures des
artistes on cherche nos premières
signatures
les neuf meilleures qu'à majorité
nomique encore
quels sont les rivaux sookie été repris
par les plus gros contrat français 1-0
quoi ça va pas du tout j'ai pas envie de
raconter ma vie mais c'est pas pour rien
j'ai arrêté les missions confiées moi
sinon je veux nique et apache musique
j'ai besoin d'être pour ça
brent remet pas dans les environs n'ont
pas besoin de ça a pris et on ouvre les
yeux on est déjà dans les embrouilles
chèrement leur peau
toi tu fais pour vous pouvez aussi bien
dormir
et mon texan de 5 à 42 56 548 je vous en
parlais par les monstres puce alloc je
crois que tu as en ronde de la tourette
tuer beaucoup se réconcilient non une
robe le mans qui a plus rien à sauver le
coup
qu'est-ce que vous l'info n'était pas dû
à la yates émis hier avant-hier j'ai
enchaîné six minutes suite si tu as
jamais tenir
j'ai peur qu'ils me gargariser ça ne
m'était pas possible à trouver des
solutions qui tournait une infirmière à
domicile
quelqu'un pour te faire le ménage corpus
comme si j'étais ma grand mère
m'a toujours dit non c'est pas possible
monsieur ya macro qui va parler j'ai
envie d'entendre c'est tout ça n'est pas
les obliger à écouter mc ren vous n'êtes
pas non plus un martyr partir vous ça
normal vous
quand vous battez c'est pathétique
en fait j'ai avec mon âge
moi ce que je voulais c'était que
monsieur mâcon ils viennent nous voir in
it is on va parler le problème c'est que
notre colère à nouveau pas légitime
dans la merde si l'on tombé dans la mer
j'ai mon couple qui explosent et les
jouets plus pourra passer et ma copine
me dit tu n'es pas tout seul d'un corps
tuméfié mais attention car si les
possibles
vous avez des lits disponibles parce
qu'on commence à avoir beaucoup trop de
monde il ya plus de kétamine vous savez
au secours ont trouvé leur nom n'a pu
bouche mans je vous admire un saison si
on ne vous savez moi je pense que je
vais bientôt tout à fait ça va un moment
de donner de sa personne tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps et de
passion de cirque on vous respecte ni
moulineaux de travail
[Musique]
vous êtes mari ou fait il n'ya pas
toujours des maris je laisse aux accents
je sais pas
il ya deux sortes de personnes pas par
tous ceux qui ont envie d'autres et ceux
qui n'ont pas sali austin désolé ça va
j'ai un filtre pour sérieux
il faut un pilote pour avoir une vie
sociale et oui y est ça en fait je ne
veux pas que tu sois dépendantes un
gadget
[Musique]
simon aprilia
bonjour part mais je suis ton meilleur
ami prêtes à l'emploi
je pars mais ton bbox est trop bizarre
je suis le be bop de barney tu viens
dans ma cabane secrète pour le light et
and our own la plante code qui te manque
qui sont si tout savoir sur moi cheveux
bruns taille un médecin quand un mètre
80 serait mieux les filles se moquerait
pas de toi il est fabriqué pour te faire
des amis demandes d'amis demandes d'amis
ils te sa personne ses gens il sert
karim
wade montre la tête peut pas les
démonter la tête pour être embêté
d'accord je peux pas lui démonter la
terre où je suis pas médias sécurisé et
tout et tout copilot trouve la cote
je vais me pencher là dessus tu crois
tu vas pas rester ici ils vont envoyer
au bois hier on va au broyeur ensemble
non le broyage sans rien d'amusant
[Musique]
pas amusant
où es tu là vous trouvez le rebelle on a
besoin de personnes doutent j'ai un ami
aujourd'hui c'est aussi triste que
pathétique au
pas de problème
salut mon grand alors ce pilote bon
allez vous deux les quatre mains en
évidence
je sais pas et un lob puis van uhm
les femmes que vous allez voir sur
toutes les patientes du plus grand
scientifiques français de notre époque
weser s'arrête bien pour m'excuser m le
docteur charcot déclenché
vous n'entendez que mahfoud
c'est pour qu'il lui fait
au rang des folles
la terre
vous pourrez tout dire
pour contaminer tout le monde
bienvenue on va commencer simplement
encore rêver sera pas plus cher
s'inquiète pas
[Musique]
d'accord mais
là
à la fère de fayots était
[Musique]
un mois qu'elle attend
ivan basso
[Musique]
le
maire
time low cost
[Musique]
la soffin
réclame le choc mon rêve